BEEN HANLEY AT
THE LINE.
NOW HANLEY C CVERY TO JAR THE PS
STICK.
DALLAS STARS COMING OFF A 3-4
OVERTIME WIN O JERSEYNELSON.
BEAUVILLIER STICKS WITH IT.
OETTINGER WAS ABLE TO TAKE THE
BOTTOM
ISLANDERS.
ALL ABOUT THE SKATING AND DOBSON
GETTING UP ON T
THIS SEASON.
>> Brendan: WAHLSTROM, TRIES TO
DANGLE THE HIGH.
SUTER WITH A SHOT TO THE FRONT,
PINBALLED WIDE.
VARLAMAME HAS AOU LAMORIELLO,
HE KEEPS YOU
MISSED.
PULOCK TAKES THE BIG OF THE ZON.
THAT'S A DOBSON HAS
ROOM ON THE FAR SIDE, GETS TO
IT.
LEAD PASS FOR NELSON,
DOBSON.
SKILLFUL PLAY.
STARS WERE TAKING AWAY THE rend
BETTER THIS EARLY: ME, TOO.
>> Brendan: WOW.
I MEAN, JUST SAWED THAT STICK IN
AINS THE LINE.
PALMIERI FROM BA
TWO-ON-ONE.
PETERSON AND GURIANOV, DUSTING .
PETERSON CATCHING THE>> Anson:
TITI IT'S IN!
BROCK NELSON'S SHOT RUNNED NG O
EDGE.
YOU SEE ANDERS LEE IN THEERES A
FROM ANTHONY BEAUVIVI LITERALLY
JUMP A LITTLE BIT WHEN PULOCK
HAD THE BIG WINDUP.
LEAGUE.
HE GETS ON HIM QUICKLY.
SEGUIN IS AROUNDOWER PLAYS
IN THE LEAGUE TO  OF PLAY.
>> Brendan: GET OUT OF THE WAY,
CAMERA.TRICK!ITIONAL PLAY.
THE ISLANDERS ARE JUST HAPPY